[Music]
foreign
hey you guys what's going on it's Sunday
Sunday after Thanksgiving
day three or day four of like the things
I was thinking it might have been Monday
but yeah no if it was Monday we would be
talking about a haunting wouldn't we but
we're not tomorrow we're going to talk
about haunting yeah this movie here
so I'm calling up this movie here I'm
calling this episode this is why we
don't like Tom pick movies yeah
the episode
no it looks I'm just I'm just [ __ ]
with you it was good Kinda Yeah Yeah
it's an Italian movie
dubbed like Italian movies are but it's
modern
and about a witch
and it looks and uh it was a demonic
witch and witch demon yeah and uh it had
some good horror scenes in it
um the direction was okay during the
horror scenes and the the uh
the
score
but this guy whoever wrote this he
cannot write dialogue not if it was like
nobody's a real person in this movie
it's a little stale when it came to the
dialogue
just not really really believable
characters really
but not a typical low budget movie
though either it's it's kind of one of
those things that's in between it
to me a lot of gialo kind of [ __ ] is
like this
no Jenny likes it a lot John movies are
a lot better than this I don't have good
enough taste to know the difference to
me I think they're kind of crappy all
right well you haven't seen a lot of
them too like you know every one of them
I've seen just kind of has a crappy feel
to it like this in a way but just more
modern crap
um
although I think had the dialogue been
written better
and and it had it not been dubbed the
movie probably would have been better
is dubbed but they're speaking English
yeah you can tell they're speaking
English well see that's the thing and
that's kind of what I was thinking about
this earlier today because I you know I
obviously give um way more consideration
to this kind of stuff but you know
that's what I do I'm a writer I analyze
things because I'm interested in that
kind of thing it's like oh how did this
go wrong and how could this be improved
in yada yada that actually like makes
you a better writer a better artist or
something like that watching bad stuff
because you can like analyze it yeah you
see what went wrong right and so the
thing about this one that I thought was
very strange I was like clearly all of
the actors
um well I mean one I'm gonna say like
the guy that directed this whose name
was uh Luca Gabriella Rossetti this was
his first uh movie which should be
pretty obvious like if you watch it now
prior to this he did work like on big
movies but he was like a visual effects
guy like he worked on um the Resident
Evil like welcome to Raccoon City he
worked on that movie
um the recent like the Coney and the
Barbarian remake so he was like a visual
effects Guy and um so him and like
another guy wrote this and this is his
directorial debut I'm gonna say I feel
like it's probably the debut of most of
the actors too because most of them were
not really all that good but it's kind
of hard to tell like I said because it
was dubbed the weird thing is that when
you're looking at it like when
everybody's talking they're clearly
speaking English but they're just as
clearly dubbed so I was like I'm
assuming that you know oh well they're
supposed to be Americans and you know
obviously they're Pro they're probably
all Italians and so they didn't want
them to have Italian accents so they
just dubbed them all over with American
voices but I'm like you know with a
couple of tweaks to the script you could
have just had them all be Italians yeah
and then they could have just talked in
their regular voices which I think would
have gone a long way toward making the
dialogue and like the acting seem not
quite so stilted yeah
I would have just let him be Italians
and speaking with it right speaking
English with an Italian with an Italian
accent and that would have been [ __ ]
great it felt real authentic because
there's no reason for them to be
Americans they didn't have to be
Americans and what were they that were
they in Italy I think they were yeah
yeah they should have just there was no
reason why they had to be Americans it's
I think he felt that maybe for marketing
purposes that's got to be that they had
to be American which no that's a big
mistake I would have done that not with
the cast that he had and I would have
left him Italians speaking either
Italian how to make two I was shot two
different versions an Italian version
where they're speaking Italian for the
his domestic market and I would have
done an international version where it
was they're speaking in English and let
them have their natural
yeah let them talk like normal because
there's like I said there's absolutely
there's literally nothing in the story
that necessitates them being American no
I think the only reason that was there
but it was because they thought like
American suckers like us would watch it
well it worked we did yeah
but it didn't it didn't make a good
impression and and so because
felt cheap because of that and a lot of
it wasn't just the fact that it was
dubbed and that the voice acting was
kind of not good yeah um
a big problem with it with it is that
the story is really laced with a bunch
of uh stereotypical kind of americanisms
to like hey we know how Americans act no
whoever wrote this dialogue doesn't know
how Americans talk and they don't know
how Americans talk to each other even
though this is supposed to be in 2000
in 2008 there's nothing really America
2008 about it even the fashion that was
not in 2000 that's another thing I
didn't really understand why it was
specifically said in 2008. again there
was no reason for it to be said in 2008
because the movie was made in 2021 so
why not just make it in the modern day
it seemed like it would be a lot easier
because I think even the cars were newer
than 2008. yeah and they're just like
shooting yourself in the dick when you
don't have a lot of fun and there was
usually when they put it in the past
they're trying to make a story that
avoids cell phones they had cell phones
in this they did just like the 2008 flip
yeah but so why why bother right uh I
would have made it in the in just in the
modern times you know in 2021 with
Italian kids where maybe you could yeah
write the dialogue a little bit better
for Italian culture where it makes sense
and because there's a lot of stuff in
this that
it's kind of like that Newen guy who
with the uh birdemic and how he thinks
America it came across kind of like that
and I think maybe it was like I said
maybe it's a Lost in Translation issue
because like maybe the writer's
directors maybe the English is clearly
not their first language and so whenever
they're writing this supposedly
naturalistic sounding dialogue it sounds
not like real people which it sounds
like an alien in a skin suit yeah
exactly somebody pretended
I would have hired an American writer to
write that dialogue but maybe he didn't
have time or didn't have access I
wouldn't have bothered though I'd admit
I'd let him [ __ ] out just let him be
attached let him be Italian and then it
would come off as real authentic and uh
be like man this is an exotic movie from
Italy and it's doing good you know
because the red the movie is actually
shot pretty well the story's okay uh the
horror scenes are good you know yeah
they're not super original but they look
nice yeah you know what I mean yeah and
it's got a good score behind it and uh
you know when you're talking about the
limited budget that this movie was put
on it was pretty good you know the
horror the horror sequences are pretty
good
um it seemed like that
the rest of the movie was just kind of
like filler to justify those horror
seeds is that they're big tonal shift
that's kind of the impression that I got
because I said you know like I said a
lot of the scenes of horror they got a
really good setting I will say that just
like this big huge like Italian Mansion
I don't know what you know where they
got it so it looks like it doesn't look
like a cheap movie you know what I mean
it looks like somebody well like I said
the guy that directed it he's a visual
effects guy like on some big movies so
he obviously knows what he's doing yeah
but I did really kind of feel like it
was a series of creepy scenes that were
not all that original but we're still
kind of well shot strung together and
they like it's like the rest of the time
they didn't really know what to do yeah
so it's like well let's yeah let's have
all these characters just like sitting
around talking and shooting the [ __ ] and
you know oh and hey boobies yeah and
then you know hey they're American and
hey they're Americans and and then it
just it didn't hang together all that
good and but you know oh and we woke up
a witch oopsie yeah it didn't feel good
it didn't feel natural it's a similar
kind of premise to an an old horror
movie called
um the evil where they go to a yeah now
that you mention it but if you look at
how the evil is edited and how that how
that story rolls on it's it's minimal
all right it's and it's just one thing
happens after another and it is the evil
actually is a good movie it it is
um and part of it is because it's not
trying to be something that it isn't
it's not trying to be too deep it's not
trying to be too
um
artistic it's more just it's just a
horror it's just like a horror ride at
an amusement park really one thing
happens after another it's all scary you
don't know what the hell's going on and
then there's ghosts and then there's a
demon yeah you know so it's a good
little story but this is a very similar
premise
and I think he should I think the
director should have gone back and
looked at something like the evil and
saw how minimal the dialogue is and or
or how it the dialogue actually should
be minimalistic in these kind of movies
and the special effects and horsing
should be kind of as much as possible
but it has to be strung together one
thing happening after the other almost
like Friday the 13th like you know the
first couple Friday dates were like that
but um yeah
I'm actually it had potential it is it's
not a terrible movie it's just there was
some decisions that were bad decisions
made I'm gonna say to you that like
overall in Italian I felt like as much
as like some of the horror scenes were
like actually good they were a little
dark I couldn't really like sometimes I
couldn't tell what was going on well
they don't want you to see that there
isn't a whole lot going on well yeah
imagination I know but they're trying to
do kind of what they did from that uh um
hereditary isn't it or isn't that the
name of that movie that you like
remember how there was like spooky [ __ ]
happening yeah he tried to do a little
bit like they did do that a couple of
times but I kind of feel like well
particularly the beginning scene because
there's actually a beginning scene that
takes place like in the late 19th
century right it takes place in the
1800s where the whole um where you find
out like with the origin I don't know if
you'd necessarily find out what the
origin of the witch is but like how the
witch got like yeah so uh how she ended
up in this Mansion or whatever and you
know there's like little kids being
killed and stuff and that part kind of
had potential like I said I kind of feel
like when we started watching I was like
oh this seems pretty good I will say
that that part went on a little bit too
long and that there were a little too
many shots of like lightning in the sky
and stuff like that which maybe was
stock footage I'm not really sure
um so then they wanted to like make it
longer I feel like this movie could have
been a lot shorter it's an hour and 43
minutes and it doesn't really need to be
that long no 20 minutes could go I mean
20 minutes could easily be trimmed out
of this is like no problem at all and so
like the beginning part I feel like you
kind of wanted to know what was going on
at the beginning like with um the guy
and like the witch and the little kids
getting dragged out and killed and the
witch getting like nailed to the tree or
whatever but it was so dark that I
couldn't really tell what was happening
like I got the gist of it but you
couldn't really see it yeah you know
what I mean
um so then there was that and then like
the rest of it
um you know when they get like they jump
ahead to 2008 for some reason and then
like all these kids show up and like I
said this massive Mansion it's like it
looks really cool I don't know where
they shot it it's like a real place
obviously
um but it's like this big Manor House in
Italy somewhere and like the one guy is
saying that he inherited it I guess like
from his grandparents yeah and you know
then later on he tells him about the
story about the Witch and all the
murders and [ __ ] like that here's the
problem with this this strange
before you get older you can't [ __ ]
pronounce anything
um I talk good
they're pretending as if this is a
spooky old place out in the middle of
nowhere that they're and it clearly is
not it is clearly a place that's in real
good condition with a manicured lawn and
it is clearly in a rich neighborhood
it's not out in the middle of nowhere
yeah but they're pretending that it is
but houses like that don't exist out in
the middle of nowhere you know they're
out with other houses that are just like
I mean there's a lot of grounds around
it like you can't see other houses
around it because it's got land and
trees and [ __ ] like that but yeah they
kind of go out there it's like oh we
went out here we've got to the place we
partied and then we discovered that the
car won't start and it's like now we
can't go get any food we're trapped here
and I was just kind of like no well and
there's like oh well let's go look
through the house like to see if there's
like some old canned goods that his
grandfather left there that you could
still eat or something 40 years ago from
like World War II yeah I know that makes
any sense uh uh the house is obviously
in good condition it's not him not uh
abandoned or anything it's got it at
least has caretakers or people living in
it it's been freshly painted actually
but yeah it doesn't look like a dump at
all it looks it's actually like really
nice no it's a beautiful location if you
look at go on YouTube and look at some
Urban exploration channels and you see
houses that have been abandoned for
decades no that's not what they look
like
back in the water [ __ ] leaking
through shit's starting to mold there's
a [ __ ] fine layer of [ __ ] dust on
everything they're they're creepy you
know
a house just can't survive forever
without an AC going on in the inside and
without people [ __ ] maintaining them
they'll slowly fall apart but they're
pretending as if they're in the middle
of nowhere
but anybody who knows anything knows
that houses like that or Mansions like
that are built in areas like Bixby
Knolls or I don't know what Bixby knows
is like nowadays but like out here in
[ __ ] where Dr Matt lived what was the
name of that place um
I'm not saying for the other one next to
it where it's just one Mansion next to
another one they got a big grounds you
can't really one match and can't see the
other
uh but it's like
there's lots of them it's like one Golf
Course next to another Golf Course next
to another Golf Course next to another
so that's what they look like and it's
going to be the same way with that house
yeah you could see the perimeter of
trees around it blocking the view of the
Other Mansions that were next to it
so it's just
it didn't need they didn't need to be
the story didn't need to say that they
were stranded they should you could have
used another method like you know some
of the British ones they couldn't leave
because there was a damn force field
remember every time they left in the car
they'd end up arriving again yeah you
know that was a good because a witch if
you're dealing with witchcraft and magic
and that's what that's what we that's
what you were seeing in the Legacy
remember the movie The Legacy
they got in the car and left and no
matter what they no matter what road
they took all roads LED right back to
the damn house yeah because if you're
opening up the supernatural you can be
like Supernatural reasons for you not
being able to leave right so you don't
have to come up with the with uh you
know
the hook yeah I did well the car doesn't
work and we're far out and I don't know
where yeah
no Mansions like that are in the middle
of nowhere really yeah and that's what I
mean and the fact that they didn't like
think to bring any food with them even
though they looks like they brought
plenty of booze and drugs though yeah
they didn't bring any food like any
snacks with them yeah that was kind of
you know and then you're you're now
missing an opportunity to where food
should have just appeared like the witch
was [ __ ] feeding them
but then it turns out later that what
they were eating was something real
[ __ ] nasty and they didn't know see
that's that's like something a witch
would do it looks like a [ __ ] Feast
[ __ ] witches man but then but then
eventually you figure out a nut was like
[ __ ] Roadkill
that you were eating you know yeah like
she put a glamor on it and made it look
really awesome it made it taste awesome
it made you think that it was but then
when you just roadkill yeah it had
maggots and words
so there's all kinds of [ __ ] or they
were eating the dead friend of theirs
yeah yeah like they're like people that
were disappeared cannibals
so you know if you're opening up a
supernatural you can run with it you
don't it doesn't take a lot in terms of
[ __ ] special effects money and I just
don't know why there's a lot of wasted
opportunity in this that kind of stuff
yeah I mean they they were doing cool
[ __ ]
and [ __ ] imagine stories and back in
the 70s and the 80s like the Legacy or
[ __ ] shock waves where they're
supposed to be on a desert island with
[ __ ] zombie Nazis but that's just up
the road here in [ __ ] Florida some
hotel I think it's I think it's still
around it's downtown
it wasn't on a desert island it was
downtown now the neutral container said
uh I kind of want to see this now uh
just because of the painting not because
I expected so bad it's good film but out
of scientific curiosity this one it's
like
I don't know it's like the horror scenes
are okay like um you know I've seen
better I've seen worse it's like they're
they're solid they're passable it's just
it's mostly like the characters and the
dialogue that is like very strange it's
like it's not quite to like the level of
the room or something like that but it
is like it's real cringe there's like a
couple of there's a couple of scenes
like there's one scene with that one
character and that other character it's
I don't remember any of their names but
um where they're like in and one of them
is like smoking pot or something and
they're talking about the whole
releasing the witch issue which none of
them believe at first because why would
you and they're sitting there going it's
ridiculous yeah that's right I agree
it's ridiculous it's ridiculous it's
ridiculous they say ridiculous like 50 I
don't know just like I was like shut up
it's like I didn't understand if that
was like supposed to be funny or if like
I was just like what I don't get like
what they were didn't come across in the
in the voice adding editing and nobody
in the voice yeah the voiceover didn't
really come off right and voice acting
as humor it just comes off as bad
writing and nobody talks like that it
would have been better if it was Italian
yeah Italian dialogue with just
subtitles would have been much better if
it was naturalistic and that's the way
Italians talk it would have come across
a lot better A lot better probably I
think and then there's like one dude
in here who's supposed to be you know
he's got a hot
goth girlfriend and
no way but yeah and I think it was a
goth girl that he was yeah that was yeah
that was that was the god girl's
boyfriend yeah and he spoke he's walking
around all [ __ ] Alpha and Macho [ __ ]
and this dude is obviously gay yeah he's
very very clear he's clearly gay I don't
buy him as a heterosexual at all no no
straight man moves like that waves hands
like that or talks like that or no I
mean we didn't hear his real voice
because
but you could tell just from his body
language yeah that that dude's gay
so it didn't fit which like I said is
fine but it's like why did I don't
understand like why they didn't just
make the character gay or why are they
trying to like so establish that he's
hetero when he's clearly not right I
just thought that was very very weird
yeah I didn't buy that he was heading
and then like later on spoiler alert but
then it turns out like what a some plot
point which doesn't actually like mean
anything or factor into anything but you
find out because we were like joking and
it's like when um the goth girl who was
his girlfriend was like talking about
like oh everything's not how it seems or
our relationship isn't isn't that good
like we were we were gonna say oh well
that they're gonna say oh well he's gay
but no it turned out she is bisexual
yeah and that she doesn't care that
she's bisexual it's not a big deal and
that she'd slept with a woman and she
like cheated on him and stuff and I was
like yeah there's another opportunity in
China yeah when they were on vacation in
Shanghai and it was like but that's
really weird that she brought that up
yeah but if it didn't matter but it
doesn't factor into anything
it was just a an americanism I think
that was thrown in there there was just
so much they had dialogue and like so
much characterization that didn't factor
into the story for some reason he
decided he had to have a goth girl in
there so there's a bunch of
stereotypical americanisms thrown in on
top of these characters but wasn't she
like supposed to be psychic too yeah and
they never really and they never really
did anything with that either because
she was talking on the phone to her
brother I think it was her brother they
established later and she was saying oh
I just like feel weird about this house
and she was like the first one that's
like saw ghosts of like the dead girls
that got killed back in the back in the
day by the witch and but that didn't
really factor into anything either no
and then they home in on her as if she's
the lead character but as far as I can
tell the ending is the ending is kind of
inconvenience inclusive but I guess she
gets killed I don't really understand
what yeah they left that hanging yeah
and then they did like a weird well they
did like an end where it seemed like I
don't know if she got killed or they
just kind of left it hanging and then
they did like a weird oh was it all a
dream thing right and then they came
back and then they kind of set it up for
a sequel it seemed like so there was
like three different things that's what
it was like a little bit I think you
were supposed to find out what happened
to her in the sequel
yeah because it was pretty obvious that
they were trying to set up a seat yeah
but the thing is is that the story
wasn't really good enough to make you
want to see the signal the the make you
want to see the sequel like I'm not like
well what happens next I really don't
care yeah that's yeah and that was the
sad thing about right they tried so much
I think to give these characters
characterization and like uh
uh character development but it was done
in such a wooden fashion that you kind
of don't care about these characters you
would have cared more about them if
there was less of the character
yeah if it was more minimal like you
know
the characters from
Friday the 13th one and two and even
three there's not much there it's pretty
paper thin but you felt like you knew
them just based on because they were
real naturalistic most of them
yeah yeah I kind of talked like real
people
I feel like particularly in a horror
movie I always think it's better and
this is a it's a it's something that I
see in novels and it's something I see
in movies and stuff like that like for
people that are you know just starting
out like writing or whatever
um is when you're doing characters
particularly in horror it's always
better to establish characters not
through dialogue or Exposition but
through the way they react to the [ __ ]
that's going on yeah
um I always think that's better and if
you're gonna have like characterization
like scenes of them like [ __ ] around
or just doing normal [ __ ] I kind of feel
like the conversations that they have
should tie in with the larger theme like
you don't really need because I feel
like that was what happened a lot in
this one there were so many
conversations and so many things that
happened in the beginning and you could
tell that they were trying to establish
character yeah but none of it meant
anything and none of it was referred to
again like what was the whole thing with
um you know I guess this did factor into
some [ __ ] but one of the guys eyes and
another thing too is that two of the
guys in here looked really similar and
one of the guys his girlfriend was
[ __ ] the other guy and for a long
time I didn't realize that she was
cheating on her with the other guy
because I thought it was the same guy
yeah and then I was like oh that's a
different guy yeah she's [ __ ] around
behind his back I was like okay I did
that didn't occur to me because the two
guys look so simpler that I thought it
was the same too and it's just like so
there was that so you know there was
this whole thing about the two of them
and it's like he was gonna propose to
her and stuff like that but then she was
[ __ ] around behind his back and it's
like but that didn't really factor into
the larger story though and like I said
the whole thing with you know the girl
be the goth girl being psychic and you
know her having relationship problems
that didn't factor into the story at all
and it's like so I felt like a lot of
the dialogue was just like wasted it was
just kind of like them just talking
about random [ __ ] that didn't have
anything to do with it it ends up it
ends up just feeling like filler and
yeah that's yeah and then it would be so
much better if the characters were
trimmed down to just their bare minimal
like I said reactions to what's going on
that's all you need to know out of them
and then instead of using them as filler
just add more scenes of stuff happening
[ __ ] that was spooky finding secret
doors finding [ __ ] pieces of a damn
spell finding this finding that people
almost getting killed an animal getting
killed you know something like that that
always happened in some of these witch
movies like The Legacy you know the
finding dogs dead or finding pieces or
somebody gets killed and you find pieces
there's a bunch of [ __ ] that should have
been done in this movie to build
attention now during the scenes when
some horror was going to happen I
thought it was effective at building
suspense and and tension I'm not scared
by any of this [ __ ] I know all the
tricks but
the score was correct the blocking was
kind of correct in that you know so
the horror elements uh I don't I don't
didn't see a problem it could have been
more more practical effects every now
and then but you know might have been
limited by budget
I mean there was some uh gratuitous
nudity so if you're into that like you
know yeah a couple of the girls showed
their boobies yeah but not much payoff
there they're no not really they're not
they're they're they're they weren't
like voluptuous by American Standards
you know
and the one scene like toward the end
with the goth girl and she was just like
hey let's just show her in the shower
you know just for no reason like I said
there was no reason but I mean there
doesn't have to be a reason because it's
titties but you know what I mean it was
like kind of titties it's kind of
titties I just thought that was like
sort of funny that they did that but
yeah I mean the scene I kind of feel
like the scene that was in the trailer
like with the room with the mannequins
that was kind of like the best scene in
the movie and like the rest of it and
even even though like having a room with
the mannequin like it didn't make any
sense or like again it didn't really tie
into the lore yeah um you could tell
that they were trying to Homage Evil
Dead in this because the goth girl was
named Ash and they found a book at some
point that looked kind of like the
Necronomicon book from Evil Dead like a
little bit so I get but it's not funny
like there's really no humor in it no so
um can we say too that the witch like
somebody was I think uh Danny was asking
about the witch like what kind of witch
it was it was kind of like a witchy
demon knee situation it was a it was a
demon it was a demonic witch that came
from hell it didn't it wasn't a I don't
know if they called it a street or a
stridge a stretch which I looked that up
is there a thing um it's kind of a real
thing uh it actually there is a
variation of that word which comes from
ancient Greek screecher and it actually
means a screech owl or it could also be
a witch so I mean and well there is like
Strega I've heard that before like as a
reference to a witch so they're not it's
not entirely pulled out of their rat
their ass all right you know what I mean
so it is it is a real thing the thing is
though is that it doesn't look all that
cool
well you can barely see it too like you
can barely see it [ __ ] it should have
looked like that damn lullaby
Rona yeah that [ __ ] that [ __ ] [ __ ]
looks scary La Llorona yeah it should
have looked I thought it did kind of
look like that when you could see it but
most of the time you couldn't see it
like most of the time it was just like
in the background yeah like just as like
a silhouette type thing a whole wedding
[ __ ] gown was [ __ ] spooky on the
layout thing and then uh or it should
have looked like the damn witch out of
the out of the that that newer [ __ ]
Witch movie where it came out and it
[ __ ] killed them all
the members of remake of that other
Italian one
you love it
um you had the poster of it okay
Suspiria oh it's the second oh the
remake of yeah the remake of Suspiria
that's what I'm saying that damn demon
that came out of during that ritual and
killed them all at the end that thing is
[ __ ] spooky looking too yeah you
killed all those other witches should
have looked like something like that
yeah
I mean I don't know I just like I said I
can see how
some of this was okay but I I feel like
this is one of the this is one of the
pitfalls of just randomly scrolling
through 2B which this was on 2B she's
magical blame me I'm not no that's not
what I was gonna say she's gonna say
Tom's gonna see some [ __ ] and go let's
watch that but hey you know well see I
told him last night it's like we need to
watch a movie I was like do you want to
watch another Universal movie do you
want to watch a hammer movie
um do you order some but then we were
just like scrolling through to be and
he's like oh that looks good let's just
watch that yeah so we just picked it at
random like we just saw like part of the
trailer and here's the thing it looked
like an American movie at first the way
they were advertising it and then after
and then we're realizing that it's
dubbed this is an Italian movie I
probably would have jumped on it earlier
or with more Augusto had it been kind of
portrayed as an Italian movie
but you know that's just us though we
don't have anything against Italian
movies but hiding the fact that it's an
Italian move doesn't make any sense
that's what I mean I do kind of feel
like they were trying to like sneak in
and sneak it in and I was like why can't
it just be an Italian movie yeah I mean
I'm not saying that the actors in This
were great actors because they weren't
but I'm just saying that they I think
they seemed worse because they were
dubbed yeah and I don't think the voice
actors were were good no so maybe if
they would just talked in their normal
voices it would have come across better
yeah because like I said some of the
dialogue in this was just it sounded
like it sounded like it was written by
somebody who English wasn't their first
language which like I said nothing wrong
with that I'm just saying that run it
through somebody who English is their
first language or make the characters
not American yeah foreign movies are
always better when they're allowed to be
foreign
work with what you got yeah we've seen
some great Spanish Italian Spanish
horror movies Italian horror movies
British horror movies just you know of
course that's English but no let them be
teeth let them be from the countries
that they come from they represent their
culture better you know if I can you
want to see okay like all right we're
going to have the Japanese tell us a
story let's go you know I'm watching
Japanese movie to see Japanese people to
hear them [ __ ] tell the story yeah
it's like we've got our we've got tons
of American movies we want to see your
[ __ ] right yeah don't try to make a
movie like our [ __ ] yeah we got those
right it's not that well that's very
retro thinking that's like something
from the 70s or the 80s that's what I
was thinking back when they were dubbing
Mad Max into English when Mad Max was is
it [ __ ] it didn't make any goddamn
sense that made no [ __ ] sense yeah
when they released the Australian Mad
Max where they were all speaking English
yeah yeah that was like what the [ __ ]
and that movie made so much more sense
when the Australian accents were in
there yes it seemed so much higher
quality yes when you hear the original
dubbing with the original track you're
like yeah oh this is a good quality
movie right yeah okay no I always
thought this was a shitty movie I yeah I
mean other than I give a pass to Yellow
movies because I'm just kind of used to
that with like that whole Gestalt
because they were all kind of dubbed so
I'm kind of used to incorporating that
and I'll give a pass also to like Kung
Fu movies because that's just funny like
when it's dubbed but overall I do not
like when movies are done and this is
the reason why I'm like I it's too
distracting that that's not that
person's voice I don't know what their
inflections sound like it always makes
the acting performance seem worse and it
makes the movie seem like a lot cheaper
yeah to see in the old Italian model of
the giallo movies is that everybody just
spoke the language that they spoke and
they would just dub it into 20 different
languages so it could play all over the
world and all over Europe because yeah
but that you don't need that anymore
people will will listen to the people
will listen to the the average the
normal dialogue
and those Productions don't have a mixed
cast anymore where everybody speaks a
different language they don't do that
anymore you can get everybody speaking
the same language and just put it out in
the language you record it in they got
subtitles nowadays and people are
watching this on Smart TVs and devices
just hit closed caption
yeah I mean I watched a movie from
anywhere I watched I always put the
closed captioning on anyway because I'm
deaf as [ __ ] and I even when they're
speaking in American I have a hard time
like they're talking in American even
when they're talking Americans you're
talking America I usually put the closed
captioning on because it's like because
mostly like most people talking sound
like you're coming through the
McDonald's drive-through speaker to me
all the time so it's like I miss a lot
of stuff because everybody sounds like
like Charlie Brown's teacher you know
what I mean I hear it but then there's
something that where sometimes it
little details would be lost on you if
it wasn't written Yeah because sometimes
people like are like whisper something I
was just like what what you know what I
mean or somebody in the background says
something's not that good yeah and then
maybe it's important to the plot so I do
so I do like to have that on a camp guy
said the same thing we use Tech
subtitles for just about everything we
watch yeah we do too
um the usually the only time I turn it
off is if I'm watching Mystery Science
Theater because then it's like too
distracting because you know then you
have like because they they do the
closed captioning on the dialogue in the
movie and then also they do all the
closed captioning of all the jokes and a
lot of times like the jokes aren't as
funny like if you can read them ahead of
time you know what I'm saying I know
that's weird because the timing yeah
because of the yeah you need the comedic
timing so usually that's the only time I
turn it off but like the rest of the
time I leave it on but I don't know I
just kind of wish they had such an
awesome location and like I said I'm as
particularly with horror movies if you
don't have a lot of money I'm always
just kind of like work with what you
have right around what you have it
seemed like they sort of did that to a
little extent like it's like we have
this fabulous mansion in Italy and we're
gonna shoot there and it looked
fantastic although I have no idea why if
you had a mansion like that you would
paint it mustard yellow but
um because I was yellow Mansion I was
like look at that oh my God and so by
the inside was like bright yellow too
and it's like why in the U.S only a drug
dealer would [ __ ] paint a [ __ ]
Mansion yellow
or like that I mean mostly because I
kind of feel like you'd want it to like
more blend into the into the
um you know surrounding landscape like
it would be kind of pretty see you know
what I mean so I don't I don't know why
you'd paint it like that like a fallen
color just like mustard yellow it was
like mustard yellow and um yeah so I
mean but you have but it was a beautiful
place it had beautiful grounds and it's
like you obviously was not abandoned
well yeah obviously like I said it was
like the lawn was mowed all the trees
were trimmed and everything yeah you
know the whole [ __ ] ground crew 24 7.
right it's massive yeah so you know the
road was all nice and neat and
everything like that everybody was clean
inside right and houses don't stay that
way if they're not being up kept yeah
10 years later that [ __ ] just looks like
a [ __ ] tomb in there yeah yeah so I
just kind of feel like they had a
gorgeous location and with some tweaks
they probably could have made this like
a d I don't think it would have been a
great movie because like I said the
story isn't that original you know what
I mean everybody goes you go on vacation
to This creepy old mansion that somebody
inherited and then suddenly somebody
unleashes a demon witch you know has
happened sometimes when you're on
vacation but I just kind of feel like
this could have been a solid movie if
they had sort of just like worked with
what they had like I said there's no
reason absolutely that these characters
had to be American and just trying to
make them American just sort of made it
I don't know didn't we see another one
like this I was reading a review of this
movie
um and actually like go on Rotten
Tomatoes and like and like read the or
IMDb rather and like read the reviews of
this which are almost all one star
um but on this one yeah other than like
two at the end that are like 10 out of
10 and I'm like that's somebody that
worked on them yeah right there but um
you know not you know and I hate to like
[ __ ] on people like that because it's
like you know people worked really hard
on this clearly it doesn't look like a
really low budget movie but I don't know
I just kind of feel like with some
tweaks this could have been like pretty
good but and some of the horror aspects
of it were okay but it just seemed like
all the dialogue and the overdubbing and
stuff like that was just so bad that it
was kind of hard to sit through to be
honest and it was too long like I said
it didn't need to be an hour and 40 43
minutes no way
um
the neutral container said I've reached
a point in my life where I even prefer
subtitles when I don't understand the
language at all I'm from Germany a
country with a huge dubbing culture
um Hugo said they just recommended me
1974 Frankenstein and the monster from
Hal with Peter Cushing is it any good is
it considered a hammer movie I don't
remember if it's considered a hammer
movie I remember it being pretty good
but I haven't seen it in a long time
slasher Fred said Mystery Science
Theater 3000 was such a classic show
yeah it is and honestly um 2B has a [ __ ]
ton of the episodes and has a bunch of
Riff tracks too because I don't know if
you know but like the the three guys
Mike and Bill and uh and uh and uh Kevin
Murphy they still do riff tracks um and
they release stuff all the time
um you know and they have the new MST on
Netflix which I actually liked well it's
not actually it was on Netflix for like
a season and a half and now they have
their own thing called the gizmoplex
which is all new people but they're but
those are pretty funny too it's a
slightly different style but it's kind
of the same concept Jeffy Hart said last
night I watched The Mummy on 2B I
haven't seen it in 30 years and I really
appreciate how much stronger it is than
Dracula the latter was good but the
mummy had a more solid narrative yeah I
agree I actually I love I I love The
Bella lagosi Dracula but um for some
reason like The Mummy
yeah I I really really well you could
tell they watched Dracula and yeah and
took notes and they were like how do we
uh how do we beat that yeah it's this
almost the same story it is pretty much
yeah it's just a different Motif laid
over it with a lot more character in it
um
of course you know directly with Baylor
ghost is [ __ ] great
but he doesn't say a whole lot say and
The Mummy
The Mummy says a lot of [ __ ] so you get
to know him a lot better I liked it too
bad the Dracula didn't have that much
dialogue or Dracula dialogue in it
because there's a lot of [ __ ] Dracula
should have said and a bunch of bunch of
[ __ ] he should have done but they were
just limited in technology and budget
and they were limited by that
the book I think they stuck to the book
a little too much
Dracula should have done more stuff once
he got to Carfax Abby
more should have happened
because not a lot happens they stake him
he has a few conversations with people
and they [ __ ] strive a stake through
him that's basically what happens
slasher Fred said one of these days you
guys should watch and review the 1989
Thriller Dead Calm oh I remember that
being really really good I'll have to
look that up because
um yeah I don't know have you ever seen
that I saw it back in the day like back
in the 90s on cable and I remember that
being really good it's like an early uh
Nicole Kidman and Billy Zane is in it
your your first wife's boyfriend yeah
yeah
you guys think that you think that
shit's funny
Billy Zane or my first wife my head
thing for [ __ ] Billy Zane whenever
she'd see him she'd start melting and
[ __ ] I could look over like that and
she'd be
[Laughter]
yeah she just thought he was [ __ ]
super hot that's funny
every time that you say that now it's
like it's yeah yeah and honestly though
every time I think of Billy Zane I think
it's like oh it's that [ __ ] from
Titanic or is that cool guy from demon
knight who made the sponge come out of
his mouth the movie that she mostly
watched and and the one to worship Billy
Zane was uh the most was has his name
Billy Zane yeah uh was Orlando
I don't think I've ever seen it though
it's actually a pretty good movie
um
it's a weird about a weird person who
started off as a man and she she's like
an immortal he's like it's paid by a
woman he's like an immortal
somebody told her that not to die I
think one of the Queens from the Middle
Ages or something told her not to die so
she wouldn't die
wow that's all it takes Queen said hey
you're not gonna die and she's like yeah
yeah she became an immortal [ __ ] and she
also had the ability to like change uh
what gen what sex she was so she started
off as a very kind of neat and then she
became a woman later on throughout the
ages and during one time she becomes a
woman and hooks up with Billy Zane
and I think he was an American
revolutionary or something I don't
really remember back in the 1700s so
that was the one year that your first
wife yeah because there's all kinds of
abdominal action in that him laying in
bed with his abs and [ __ ] around and I'd
have [ __ ] look over look at her like
that and she was just licking her lips
and I said you didn't [ __ ] knock it
off she's literally
he's all right I never really she liked
his lips you know
oh yeah I guess I guess so she just
thought I don't know I never really
thought about it but yeah yeah he's an
okay looking dude to me he always looked
a little bit a little bit like the dude
from Kiss [ __ ] what was this what's
that dude's name wait which one [ __ ]
do the tongue Richard Brown said Tilda
Swinton played Orlando oh maybe I should
watch that because I actually yeah I
love her it's actually a pretty good
movie it's all this went into school I
don't think I've ever seen it
um
from [ __ ] not Peter Chris the [ __ ]
um the Gene Simmons Jim Simmons yeah for
some reason he reminds me of a handsome
Gene Simmons
not say Gia Sims is ugly but
yeah he is kind of when he was young he
was [ __ ] look good but you know he's
older now
slasher Fred said if you guys ever see
the underrated horror comedy film Jack
Frost oh I've seen it it's great it's
hilarious I haven't seen like any of the
um sequels but the first one's like
[ __ ] hysterical yeah but a serial
killer who becomes a snowman
um I wanted to say like before we got
too far away from uh the movie The
unkind that we're talking about oh one I
wanted to say
why is it called that why is it called
the unkind because that doesn't have
anything to do with anything I wanted to
this okay so this is a little bit this
is kind of like emblematic of the kind
of thing that I'm talking about because
this is the synopsis
from IMDb and it sounds like it was
written by whoever wrote the script okay
um so this is what it says it says in
2008 six friends from NY New York decide
to vacation together in Italy comma they
think which that should be a period
there but okay uh they think they are in
for a smooth and easy two weeks full of
beers partying and fun their vacation
soon turned Sinister when strange thing
starts to happen and more than that when
they learn of the Mansions without an
apostrophe devastating history and
realize that there is more to the house
than anyone could have expected after
accidentally they find a book that take
them to a sealed grave they unleash an
ancient witch a stridge an unnamed and
Unstoppable demonic Force thirsty of
blood no who who wrote this I don't know
that's what I'm saying but I said this
sounds like the same person that wrote
the dialogue
the group goes out of control the
mansion and the forests surrounding with
no success I don't really even know what
they were trying to say there the witch
claimed them to certain death one after
the other Ashley the more empathetic of
the group wakes up with a start on her
apartment in NY City she is shocked
flight tickets for Italy on the table in
front of her and his boyfriend Nick is
taking a shower was it only a dream or
perhaps a premonition that's the
synopsis that's on IMDb remember there
was one line in this that cracked us up
he said that um like how did the how did
the woman that was the witch die and the
guy said he wounded her he wounded her
to death and I was like what how do you
wound somebody I mean technically
technically yeah true but I was like
what a weird what a weird way to put
that an American would not even conceive
of a sentence like that he she was
wounded to death yeah he said he
wouldn't I wounded her to death you mean
beat her to death I think maybe that's
yeah
you're talking about this that's the
closest way to yeah but he didn't beat
her to death he impaled her on a tree
branch I think well that's what it said
in the in the other wound and somebody
to death that's killing somebody to
death
he killed her today
doesn't make any [ __ ] sense in
America that was like the line that made
me laughed
there's also some weird [ __ ] that
happened uh uh when they with the with
the little van they had a little
Volkswagen van that they came in yeah
and there's a scene where they try to
leave but they can't because there's
just a dead animal in the engine
yeah and they show it it looks like a
little [ __ ] it looks like pepper a
baby beaver I don't know what it was
supposed to be I don't know just stuffed
up against one you know the side of it
we're like how would that make your car
yeah they're stuffed up next to the
[ __ ] exhaust manifold
and uh
because we'll try to they couldn't get
it started and then so we'll try to fix
it later you have to go and get like
Parts but there's no place around here
to get parts we're stuck here yeah in
the closeted guy the undercover gay says
he's working on it okay it's gonna take
him several days but they don't have
engine parts I'm like man dialogue like
this wouldn't even [ __ ] fly in
[ __ ] that would not fly in Italy come
on Italy has a long history of
Motorsports you know they know how
engines work yeah engines work whoever
wrote this doesn't have it you know if
it if a dead animal is on top of the
engine that doesn't mean you need new
parts and have to do an engine rebuild
what what
is spun a bearing what you what you
[ __ ] broke you threw a rod come on
man it's a [ __ ] well I think it would
have been creepier like I said because
the whole thing is supposed to be
Supernatural
it wouldn't start and that would be even
creepier because it's like we can't
figure out what the problem is
everything looks fine so riding problems
like you said we tested the battery
battery is good but the car won't start
everything looks perfect why won't it
start like they can't figure it out that
would be creepier you can even pull a
plug and go look it's getting sparked
why isn't it starting right you know and
you don't have to know that much about
cars to write that right you know what I
mean right ask a dude that works at
Jiffy Lube right for minimum wage he'll
tell you no it's got fuel it's got fire
it's got air it's turned it over but it
won't start it won't start we can't
figure it out yeah we can't figure it
out yeah that's what I mean that's all
you have to be a lot more that'd be a
lot more Sinister if you have the right
music playing
yeah because because there wouldn't be
any reasons
because we've got Germans we even got
Germans in the audience we said then
they go then a German dude comes in here
and goes let me stand aside stand back
you [ __ ] Italians yeah
industrial lights come in here engine no
problem
I'll make a new engine with a file give
me a [ __ ]
yeah
okay
you need a file and a pair of calipers
I'll get you a new crankshaft in four
hours don't worry
yeah Jeffy art said I saw an episode of
news radio where one of the characters
reads this book that was translated
re-translated from Japanese it sounds
like it was recycled through Google
translate yeah super puppy happy man go
bye-bye yeah it's like it wasn't quite
that bad but it was kind of like that
you could tell that whoever wrote it
like yeah English wasn't their first
language which like I said I'm not
[ __ ] on people who English is their
second language of course but it's like
you know kind of get somebody that knows
we live in the age of the internet you
could have subbed that out right to
massage that [ __ ]
um script a bit so it was more organic
and more more American sounding although
I'm gonna back up and says this these
should have never don't even make them
Americans don't make them America it
should have been Italians
yeah and it would have been a much
higher quality product in appearance and
feel if it was just Italians
even if they had he wanted to do an
English version have him speak in their
own language big thick accents and [ __ ]
it'd be cool as [ __ ] yeah yeah well I
mean look at this [ __ ] man they put
Asia Argento and [ __ ] American and
British movies all the time and she has
a super thick Italian accent any
complaints about that yeah you know what
I mean they don't usually dub or
sometimes right and maybe we would
understand their behavior a little bit
more if they weren't Americans you know
some of the way they're treating women
go away get away from me go going back
in the house I'd do his boss and that
girl around
and then like every time you weren't
even fighting and then yeah he was just
amazing go back inside go back inside
I'd be like [ __ ] you dude yeah yeah
well and then the one guy who I thought
was the other guy who was [ __ ] around
with the other guy's girlfriend which
like I said I didn't even realize she
was [ __ ] around for like half the
movie because both the dudes look the
same so I was just kind of like and then
that guy like every time you did
something that that guy didn't like he
was a [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] I was
like I hope that guy dies first
did he die ah I think they all died
didn't it yeah maybe they all did I
think spoiler alert
yeah I think they all died I think they
pretty much all did they chained to
those trees yeah that's right
um Danny Rowling said is this film
better than return to Salem's Lot yeah
yeah yeah yeah return to Salem's Lot was
pretty bad yeah the return to Salem's
Lot has had some some uh entertainment
factor to it
you know what I mean it was kind of
entertaining it was it was bad you know
yeah it was yeah I was I was kind of
feeling like I was laughing I was
feeling like contact embarrassment yeah
well the thing about it is that
embarrassed you know what I mean well
it's just kind of I felt bad for
everyone involved and look well like I
said it's weird because it's in like
this weird ambivalent gray area where
it's not so terrible that it's like
hilarious because some of it was like
competent yeah but then there was like
some parts of it that I was just like oh
and I was just like cringing like that
like the whole time like mostly like the
dialogue scenes yeah you know and it's
just like all of these pointless
conversations they were having like the
whole thing it's like oh by the way I'm
bisexual and I slept with a woman and I
was like okay what is that what bearing
does that have on anything that's going
on in this movie like nothing and it's
just like I don't know it was weird like
all these conversations they had and
then whatever happened to that one other
girl that wasn't quite as hot as the
other ones like did she get killed she
just like kind of disappeared from the
movie I thought maybe I missed it
because like I said the horrorary scenes
were were competently done but they were
very dark so a lot of times like I was
like wait what just happened
the neutral container said okay I'm
pretty sure I'll try and watch this now
because it does seem to have some so bad
it's good stuff in it yeah particularly
like all the dialogue stuff but I'm
gonna say that
um some of it's just kind of like boring
so because it's long
and there are two other movies that are
like this in a way that are a lot better
the Legacy
that's going to a mansion with witches
all right that you can't leave all right
and the other one be the evil which is
going getting trapped into a big house
like this that has
ghosts and a devil in it both of which
are from 1978. yeah but yeah
this movie is kind of feels like a
spiritual descendant of those but one
that has got special needs yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
rude yeah
[Laughter]
yeah it's almost I really I wanted to
like this movie I mean like I said the
the poster looks cool the concept is
cool like I said it's not original it's
just like you know killer demon witch
and matter of fact I just read a novel
that has not the exact same premise but
it's also like a demon witch kind of
story and I was like oh that's weird and
it's weird because now that I'm talking
about the movie I keep wanting to talk
about the book because I just finished
reading that it's because it says the
same demon witch kind of angle to it but
I mean you know but it was like it would
have been a solid story it's just that I
really wish
there was better acting and like better
voiceovers and like just some tweaks to
the story like there were and and edited
edit like about 20 minutes out of this
I would say 70 of this movie's problems
would have been alleviated just by being
Italian dialogue the Italian language
would have I think that would have
helped immensely
yeah
and yeah doing that and cutting out
about 20 minutes mostly of like dialogue
or establishing character [ __ ] because
nobody cares about that
um you know what I mean Whittle the
conversations down to just the bare
minimums and just to keep the movie
wrong or like I said make them at least
more relevant to the plot at large don't
just make it like a bunch of random
tendrils that have nothing to do with
anything script would have been better
had it been in Italian because an
Italian person writing it would write
like an Italian speaks yeah so it would
so it would seem like a lot more natural
yeah I mean it's difficult enough
writing in your native language like
writing a good story in your native
language uh I can't imagine like even if
I could competently speak any second
language like I can't imagine writing
another story in that and like trying to
yeah convey like a person that's from
that place when I'm not from there
because like a lot of there are a lot of
things that you don't think of right and
tacky American
and a tacky American americanisms
cultural americanisms wouldn't have to
be included like is it just a tacky
scene where
little hottie runs up on her boyfriend
her ass cheeks are hanging out of the
back of her [ __ ] pants and we're like
yeah okay she's American right is that
you're saying
and then she jumps up on him and
straddles him just in a hug to say hi to
him like yeah that's kind of like
[ __ ] pardemic where white people just
sit around and [ __ ] uh straddle each
uh sit on each other's laps that's what
dating is to is is to sit on people's
laps that's how Americans date
and that if you meet a girl in public
you can follow her home and knock on her
door and say I saw you on the street
you're just the most beautiful thing
you're gonna get shot like I said okay
you're amazed at the very least
that girl's gonna [ __ ] run out there
[ __ ] grab the grab a [ __ ] shotgun
and call the cops you're lucky if she
doesn't [ __ ] shoot you okay this is
[ __ ] America all right
yeah well we don't play that here no you
follow a woman home that's attempted
rape
basically yeah well that's very
threatening hell yeah it's just really
weird how dudes would not understand
that that's very threatening behavior
like this would understand I'm like
[ __ ] I don't know you dudes would
understand that well no I'm just saying
they do that everywhere dude there's no
there's no dude in the west that would
ever follow a girl home you're gonna I
mean unless they had bad intentions yeah
which just curious just proves the point
that's something my dude over and where
was he from Philippines I think he was
from Philippines to Thailand Filipino or
something like that I can't remember
yeah Vietnamese that's something in the
Far East you might dream up that's how
you meet a white girl you just see her
and you follow her
keep following eventually she'll break
down she'll go out with you to me is
that while we're home I mean they did
that a lot well they did that a lot in
old movies
too like I kind of feel like older
movies yeah yeah I I love you so
therefore you love me so you have to
love me back whether you want to or not
yeah that was 20s yeah like they would
just keep like stalking you like you
know what I mean it's showing up where
you were I'm like dude yeah put on a
list for that and the woman would be
smiling like I got him now this sucker
but then you know I I don't know you
know if I can win I guess they were just
trying to
let it be known that what women are
dying to get married to the first guy
that comes along is that what it is uh
yeah I think that's it well like I said
a lot of women didn't write those movies
yeah just some guy fantasized women are
dying to get married to the very first
guy that comes along yeah yep you'll do
yeah you'll do oh someone paid attention
to me yeah yeah it's time for me to get
married
which yeah that's not how that should
work so it was pre-dating culture I
guess so well the funny thing about the
scene in burdemic It's not just that I
mean that whole like lap scene that you
were talking about yeah it's not just
that it wouldn't have been weird it's
like if they were on the couch in the
living room like having sex like she was
straddling him yeah but they weren't
they were both fully dressed he was
laying there and she was straddling him
and they weren't moving no or they
weren't even like looking at each other
it was so bizarre yeah and I was just
like sitting there going what are they
doing it's enough
it was so weird it's a non-westerner's
interpretation of Western dating culture
it was just so weird I'm just like this
this like someone from outer space like
try to like what the [ __ ] is that about
that's like not even like oh a cultural
difference I'm just like that's that's
another species I'm sorry Zach says it's
like how in Period movies characters are
using old slang every five seconds and
I'm like I'm pretty sure people didn't
talk like that yeah it's like you put it
back into like hey 23 skadoo blah blah
you know what I mean it's like yeah I'm
just you know people weren't talking
it's like maybe every now and then well
because people don't use slang
nowadays that would be like you know 40
50 years from now like somebody made a
movie that was set this year and like
they made the whole movie and everybody
was talking in like emojis and like you
know like text kind of stuff like that
and it's like people don't talk like
that yeah you know but yeah I get what
you're saying I get what you're saying
but yeah
um so this movie if you're curious is
called the unkind and it's on 2B like I
said we just kind of came across it
randomly like while we were scrolling
it's kind of funny looking back on it it
is yeah unintentionally but it's
unintentionally it's not like I said
it's not bad enough to be like hilarious
no
so you actually competently made yes
it's just the script and the dialogue
mostly like I said we're not talking
about like a birdemic or the room or a
Troll 2 situation where it's just like a
[ __ ] show of epic proportions and it's
just hysterically funny yeah it's not
hysterical it's more like it got some
Chuckles out of us though I think though
I think he wounded her to death was like
maybe yeah
like I said most of the movies problems
would disappear if it was just in it if
it was just Italians you know Italian
speaking in Italian right
um and if the characters were written to
be Italian I think a lot of the problems
would have vanished would have vanished
yeah yeah
uh the neutral container said uh that
reminds me the Germans in Vanquish from
2021 were terrible and were clearly
played by Americans that's another way
this can go yeah I just kind of wish
that like I said right around what you
have like especially if you're a low
budget like if you have actors that are
a particular you know have a particular
accent or whatever just make the
character from there it's not like
that's a big deal like in the story and
if you don't have Germans don't make
Americans be Germans just you know
do we have any Germans do we have any
laying around look in the back maybe
[Laughter]
write the story around what you have
write the story around what you have and
it will seem like a lot more
naturalistic instead of trying to like
force things into an idea that you have
when you don't really have the time or
the budget like if you you know if
you're making a movie for like 250
million dollars you can afford to get
whoever the [ __ ] you want then that's
different yeah I haven't seen a good
German movie really I don't remember any
I can't think of a German movie that I
like downfall yeah downfall was pretty
good
um
um Dead Snow
yeah
I don't think I saw that one I don't
think that's no is German wasn't it I
don't think I saw that movie oh you'd
like it the uh zombie Nazis
the although the Germans can make good
music man and real good music videos
rammstein's music videos the new ones
are [ __ ] excellent uh they had good
ones even back in the day but uh I
looked at some of the new Ramstein stuff
[ __ ] dick titten [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] hilarious man and uh the one
where they're going through the ages
shows the Germans got the ages and in
the end there's a bunch of them
gangster rappers and [ __ ] [ __ ] the
band it's just hilarious you know
um but now they had some good [ __ ] good
quality stuff
um
but I haven't seen any good German
movies
other than just like is it downfall
that's kind of old now that's at least
what 20 years old probably yeah when did
that come out
I can't remember I don't know if they're
making anything right now but you know
they're making art films and [ __ ]
nothing wrong with that you don't [ __ ]
on our films Danny Rowling said uh
what's tomorrow's a haunting review
episode gonna be well you sent me a
message that had three different ones so
we'll probably do one of those maybe
we'll do Casa de los Muertos or did we
do Spellbound
I had some witches in it and some Gothic
witches in there
yeah and then I can't remember what the
other one was I wrote it down but it's
like over there so let's do Spellbound
well I gotta check and make sure we
haven't done that one already okay but
so it'll either be Spellbound or it'll
be Casa de los Muertos which is actually
on that disc right there because that's
the same disc that had um the last one
we did on it I don't think I know we
haven't done Casa de los Muertos we'll
just do that yeah we haven't done that
one yeah so okay we'll do Casa deals
because I know we haven't done that one
yeah I'm sure we haven't done that one
yeah Pat says uh if it's on to be this
movie uh that means I can watch it but
should I from what I'm hearing I think
the answer is a resounding now I mean
it's up to you uh it depends on if you
have better things to spend an hour and
43 minutes on like I said it's not
it just falls into this gray area like I
said I'm a big app like if something's
gonna be bad be so bad it's good like be
over the top and hilarious this one
doesn't really fall into that like I
said it's like it's half
okay and then the other half is like
pretty cringy but it's not so bad that
it's
it's kind of like it's well it's not as
bad as something like Ouija shark
but which is you know terrible looked
like it was made for five dollars but
it's kind of like the same Spirit where
they had kind of like
I don't know although I feel like Ouija
shark they're like oh we have this wacky
idea but that's about as far as they
took it like they didn't really they and
then the rest of it was just kind of
half-assed yeah I've seen 80s porn with
a tender story
yeah yeah it's true
they're obviously just making it up as
they're going along right just having
um cute American Girls scandily clad
with boobs and jumping around and
washing cars and stuff that just and
they're being you know they're they're
being Shameless about it they know what
they're doing but that gets bored real
quick you know
like the those girls are not gonna have
sex the the movies I don't even think
it's rated R so why are you watching
this you know it's like yeah just watch
porn yeah it's like if this isn't gonna
turn into porn right now
you could even leave the shark in it if
you want yeah and you just left the
shark in it made it porn
Ouija porn sure porn sure
Ouija porn shark XXX
and it would have been but the thing is
they don't make porn movies anymore I
don't think why would you waste time
I'll make it a full a full length full
length feature film like they used to
well because back in the day you had to
go to a theater and it's like you didn't
want to feel like you wasted your money
yeah yeah you know what I mean they were
doing Oscars and doing Awards pre and
everything back in the 70s doing their
own version of the Oscars yeah yeah uh
neutral container said dark was great
that's right I forgot all about that
there's a Netflix series I I love I
loved that I loved that I think I saw
like one episode or saw a part of an
episode you were watching yeah I think
it was three seasons that was one you
really had to pay attention to because
it was very very complicated it had to
do with like a lot of time travel and
all this stuff yeah I mean you had to
have you had to have like [ __ ] doors
you had to have like a [ __ ] flow
chart like to figure out like who and
there was like versions of all the
characters like at different ages and
like yeah this guy it was yeah you
really had to like pay attention not for
me uh Pat says we just shark can't
possibly be as bad as shark Exorcist
shark seriously I remember shark
Exorcist yeah did we see sharks on that
one too I think yeah I don't remember
that one no Ouija shark was worse
yeah yeah
out of those kind of movies of course
[ __ ] philosophaster is the best one
that's actually an excellent film it is
hilarious yeah it goes all the way
around it becomes like awesome and they
know what they're dealing with and they
know how to [ __ ] with you I have that
don't I
it's a good movie I'm pretty sure that's
also free on 2B yeah or it used to be I
don't know if it is anymore
all right so um we've gone on for like
an hour yeah you want something to eat
yes okay all right so yeah tomorrow uh
is haunting Monday so we're gonna do
Casa de los Muertos yeah so that should
be fun yeah because I'm sure we haven't
done that yeah and that's I remember
that being like a good episode and I
don't think I've seen it it's almost to
the point where it doesn't matter if we
did it or not if we get the same amount
of hits everybody still love it because
we just be doing it again that would
have been back before we were even on
camera
back when we just did before but when we
were just invisible when we were
disembodied voices and then when people
saw us for the first term like man we
didn't think you guys would look like
that but see I think that every time
that I listened to somebody for a really
long time and then I see them I'm just
like that's absolutely I'm not I'm never
sure like what I exactly expected them
to look like but I'm like well not that
right that's like all I can yeah so if
you'd asked me to like describe them
like I wouldn't have been able to yeah
the first time they saw Jenny was just
out of the cleavage and boobs and
they're like whoa I think we had like
[ __ ] uh three or four hundred dollars
in super chats that day on that first
show remember that no I don't remember
that the first time we streamed I think
we got yeah I think we had 300 or 400 in
super I remember we streamed like I
think the first time we streamed was
like one of our like big apps like the
250 200 or 300th or something like that
yeah
and we didn't have a studio or anything
it was just a back it was just in we
were just in a room it's just a wall
just a wall my old office at the old
house yep all right so thanks for
dropping by today everybody talking
about this kind of not that great movie
uh so we'll see you guys again tomorrow
talking about haunting that should be a
lot of fun we'll have some drinks and
talk about some haunting [ __ ] so have a
good rest of your evening and we'll see
you guys again tomorrow bye